Sam's gonna start dating.
You and I, weren't much older when we met.
Maybe it's time for us to take a step back.
You wanna know how to get the girls?
I'm taking you to Poon City.
That's not a real place.
Nope!
Not doing that!
There are strategies.
You could teach him.
I'm not a little kid anymore.
I can do things!
Strategies for when you get your heart broken?
Sometimes, I wish I was normal.
Hey dude, nobody's normal.
Your son has the same desire to be loved that we all do.
Paige!
Why shouldn't he pursue it?
My family is fragile.
Everything is "Sam this" and "autism that".
It's time for you to have your own life.
Whoever first said "Practice makes perfect" was an idiot.
Humans can't be perfect...
...because we're not machines.
The best thing that you can say about practice is that it makes better.